i fell asleep while i was getting it
what i was getting done i don't even
know how i ended up falling asleep on
this
like any hurt at all right yeah he got a
recycle how do you know
we did a little research
[Music]
i always wanted to get tattooed i just
ain't never had nobody that would like
to do him if my brother got tattoos
everywhere but i didn't like the dude
that was doing my brother tattoo that's
why i never got a tattoo when i was
younger when i went to l.a
um like 2017
i ended up seeing like this tattoo
artist on instagram and i'm like i like
how he do tattoos so he did most of my
tattoos besides this one right here
i actually got this tattoo done on black
ink crew on the tv show
it's just some money on my hand that's
it it's just some money i don't got a
lot of tattoos though i like tattoo i
don't got a lot of tattoos though i
don't know i just got them in all the
spots that matter what was my first
tattoo
my first tattoo was this right here this
whole little front sleeve i got all this
for my first session
well they say ybn which is our brand
with a crown on it
and uh just a little done i just needed
something to fill it in with so i i just
told him to put like a dub
i kind of wish i can't get this dove
though because i don't like it no more
but
i think it's kind of too big to cover up
though so i just i just leave it like
that
i was 18 when i got my first tattoo but
it kind of hurt it a little bit but like
i went back the next week and i got this
tattoo right here
i got the other side so i was just
trying to knock out as much space on my
arm as i could
the tattoo dude that did this i seen
like
this picture on his instagram like he
kind of did it for somebody else
but i really liked it so i just told him
i wanted it and he just changed it up a
little bit so it didn't look exactly the
same like i don't but all my tattoos
like got meanness behind it though
beside this one like i just wanted this
on instagram
i wish i didn't even get this like i
don't even know why but i have a draco
tattooed on my arm
i kind of wish i didn't get it though
like i'd be looking at this sometime
like
i got a whole gun tattooed on my own in
a box with some chopsticks
but i got this tattoo because like my
sewing chopsticks i was like i got a
chopstick
af and a jacob hold on so i got a draco
and a box of chopsticks tattooed on
i mean it's so big like i can't even i
don't even know what i would cover it up
with like it's just
it's so big sorry i think it's just that
big i just i had to leave it
my favorite tattoo it got to be the one
on my chest for sure my chest tattoo
it's a piece on my side holding some
money i got this tattoo on my chest like
three months ago he looks like a rich
baby on my chest like
just holding money it came from a
picture and i like the picture of
himself i'm just gonna get that picture
tattooed
i fell asleep when i was getting it done
i don't even know how i end up falling
asleep on this by getting hurt at all
[Music]
he was there when i got it done he knows
like he was pointing at my chest while i
was getting done and he was saying sir
like circuit that's his name so he was
pointing at my chest like sir sir
one day i woke up i was like i want to
get a neck tattoo but i ain't going to
get nothing crazy so i figured if i just
got my sun name tattooed on my neck that
it'll be cool
it's like roses on both sides i think
and there's like
like flowers around it i got legend
tattoo behind
my ear right here i got this tattoo in
like 2018.
legend how that came about i'm kind of
like the first person where i'm from to
actually like
be successful like where i'm from that
was like some legendary
to me so i just like looked at myself
like a legend
and i got a crown on this side i got the
crown the same day
i got the legend tattoo so i just like
i'm put legend right here and i'm just
gonna get a crown here
because i always call myself king all my
dj before i call myself i've been on my
channel so that's where the crown
that's why i adopted like the crown so
that's how i get
i got the crown right that you would not
get
here
tattoo on my face i would never tattoo
my face i don't need attention on my
face
but i do but i don't i don't know it's
confusing but if i do get a face tag it
might be like right here so
i wouldn't tap my foot though that's the
place i wouldn't touch it i wear pants
most of the time like i only like
wearing shorts
so like it wouldn't even make no sense
for me to get my legs out too
do you have any sort of blueprint for
the rest of your tattoos
i think when i drop my first project i
might get my project
name tattooed on me somewhere like i
gotta get my project
i might get it right here like right
right right by my hairline i might get
it like right
if it don't look crazy i want to get my
back tattoo too though i don't have no
tattoos on my back but i do want to get
my back tension
i think i got enough room right here to
like tattoo like something else right
here so i might tattoo my sister
my sister face my hair i listen
immediately
i'll be putting numbing cream on it when
i get tattoos like i don't know i can't
sit there and get no straight tattoo
like i don't know
like but like afterwards when the
numbing cream and [ __ ] rub off it'd be
like on fire
i think my neck took the longest i
thought it was gonna hurt like all my
atoms happen when i was getting attacked
but i didn't really feel it
it only hurt it like on the side so like
when you started hitting the side i was
like hold on like you got to stop
living like it was hurting back how many
times
i want to finish like my whole
overwatching so i'm for sure gonna get
my stomach down
i might go like next week and get my
stomach done and then just like
fill in like all the other spaces that i
need tattoo i try not to get like crazy
tattoos like this draco when i got this
draco tattoo my mom was like why the
hell you got a gun tattooed on y'all
and i was like i don't know i just got
it because my song
but like i try not to get tattooed like
that like i try to get something like 20
years you know
when i'm older like that i can look at
and be like i actually like like this
tattoo but i know for a fact i ain't
gonna like this
i tattoo know she wasn't a fan she liked
like the idea of having my sunday
tattooed on but she ain't like
that i got my neck tattooed she was like
why would you get your neck tattooed
maybe you should get your mom's
name tattooed i'm not really like a fan
like the name
[Music]
what would you say to your said that he
wanted to son
tattoos i'll let him i don't see why not
i like tattoos but
just don't get no crazy tattoo like
don't get nothing that
you wouldn't want to see like for a long
time like go to somebody that actually
got like experience don't go to no
damn garage and get no garage tattoo
because your homeboy know how to attack
and he got a tattoo going he tried to
learn how to take